well welcome Tom to Microsoft research
and it's great having you here as part
of giving your distinguished lecture
tomorrow at Microsoft Research AI just
getting going about some of your
background and interests I'm just
curious how you got interested in
machine learning to begin with and you
started out in Oberlin and were you
always interested in mechanism and
machines or how'd you get into AI well I
guess I was always interested in kind of
engineering things my I had an uncle who
is an MIT PhD who worked in numerical
control milling machines and and then he
was one of the early people he's working
for General Electric on the Dartmouth
time-sharing system so so as a young kid
I got a chance to write in basic on a
teletype dialed into Dartmouth from
Maryland which is where he was not had
any end up giving you time on this
machine but but but then and so I was
always doing computing and and you know
in those days when you applied to
college you said well what computer do
they have because they would have only
one right
and so Oberlin had an IBM 360 model 44
as well as a wrist us 11 pdp-8 I think
or me was pdp-11 so I really wasn't I
you know I was I I considered many
majors along the way I was always taking
a lot of math because that was fun but
one of the ones I considered was
political science and one of the classes
in political science was a philosophy of
political science and my professor
instructed me to read Thomas Kuhn
structure of scientific revolutions
because he said you know Karl Marx
claimed that he was a scientist Marx did
and and here's what Thomas Kuhn thinks
science is what do you think which was
very provocative because in some sense
some people might accuse Kuhn of being a
quasi Marxist right and he had all these
interesting ideas about big scientific
paradigm paradigm shifts and but the
incommensurability of vocabulary and
some of the sort of subjectivism that
maybe Marx also advocated right this I'm
getting lost know how its communicated
say I any case then
I decided to go to to at least get a
master's in computer science and I went
to Illinois and I was offered a research
assistantship by Richard Mikulski and
and it was about what we now call
machine learning but in my spare time I
was hanging out in the philosophy
library reading about the philosophy of
science because I thought well if I'm
gonna be doing this machine learning
stuff I should be trying to understand
how is it that we learn about the world
and and what are the sort of
foundational principles and so that led
me into a lot of these kind of questions
about inductive logic conformation
Theory incarnate Carnap yes and and then
sort of I don't know you know through a
connection with Donald Michie I I was
introduced to Bruce we can and who lo
and behold was a philosopher of science
and so then he offered me you know a
research position as a graduate student
at Stanford and so these things kind of
snowballed but while I was still a
master student at Illinois you know Tom
Mitchell and I'm jaime carbonell and and
Richard organized the first machine
learning workshop which was at CMU in
the summer of 1980 and all 20 of us or
whatever were in the room and so that
was the that's they decided to to revive
the term the Arthur Samuel had chosen of
machine learning as being the name of
the field led wheel is it that other
seminal chose that that phrase yeah I
think one of the titles into one of his
first papers is some studies of machine
learning on the game of checkers or
something like that at the agency if
some of the early working machine
learning that I've read over the years
really seems to have laid out the whole
architecture of modern machine learning
quite early like in the early sixties in
fact some great work was done well
especially if yeah if you go to say you
know Nils Nelson had this book learning
machines in 1967 maybe and and then and
do-don heart I think particularly what a
beautiful book they wrote yeah you
mentioned that somewhere I saw you
mentioned that you're you have research
attention disorder a deficit
attention deficit disorder I guess it's
like I think people that are the most
fun in the field seem to be
intellectually promiscuous in other
words nothing the deaths around with
attention deficit disorder but they go
deep in several different areas over
time and they make links among those
areas that I always think that's kind of
an interesting thing too as a way to do
science mm-hmm right well and so yes I
mean I think you also may be suffering
from a better enjoy yeah I mean I find
basically all of these sort of every
aspect of artificial intelligence
fascinating and I've also always wanted
to have one foot in some sort of an
application setting because of course we
came of age kind of maybe in reaction to
the to the artificial intelligence of
1965 to 1975 which was all about the
blocks world and kind of toy problems
and it was pretty clear that things that
worked on those problems didn't really
work on anything else you know and I
like to think of the history of
artificial intelligence as the period of
the known knowns when it was fully
deterministic fully observed systems and
then we had the known unknowns period of
you know you do pearl and probabilistic
reasoning over fully observable things
more or less and then we've moved now
into the unknown unknowns of how do we
give systems that really work in open
worlds where the computer does not have
a full model of what's going on in fact
I think you've pointed out that having a
full model in a world with with by
definition limited datasets is actually
desired but for the fundamental you know
theorem of machine learning right what
because yes in in machine learning we
have we have learned that right that we
if we don't have enough data then we
have to use a deliberately oversimplify
our models you want to do that yes in
order to get the the best say
performance classification accuracy or
or predictive accuracy and this is
something that's deeply disturbing if
you've been raised in the realist
philosophy of science which says well
there is a real reality out there
the electrons really exist for instance
even though we can't observe them and
and our goal is to understand that but
if you come from the instrumentalist
community which is where Bruce began
brought me up to be we're really
interested in sciences is is important
as it is useful to solving the problems
that really care about now I you know I
know if we had deeply shared interests
in the open world and the the
implications of limitations in the
technology in terms of influences on AI
people in society more broadly and
you've done some really fascinating
review work and some deep dives into
what it will take to build robust AI
what we're up against in in trying to
achieve robustness in our AI systems as
we feel them in the open world and
you've had a few ideas like like the
idea of open category learning for
example and to make some comments on
where you are with that well so yeah I
mean this began with an application
problem right I was working with
ecologists and people at the
Environmental Protection Agency and they
want to assess the health of freshwater
streams in the United States and one way
they do that is to example the bugs that
live in those streams so it turns out
you know if you have an insect larvae
that may live for a month in a stream
it's it's in some sense drinking the
water the whole time and so if it's
alive and healthy then that's pretty
good sign that the stream is healthy so
we had collected specimens while our
collaborators had collected a hundred
specimens each of 54 different species
of these kind of indicator insects and
we built a computer vision system that
could automatically recognize them and
we were very excited that it was like 92
percent correct on 54 classes until we
found out that well if we were dealing
with real field samples they would
contain a lot of other stuff besides our
54 species because there are something
like 2,000 species of insects that live
in these rivers not to mention insect
shaped leaves and and little stones and
things that might fool the computer
vision system and and our system failed
miserably when it was
these these we call them aliens now but
these new at least new to the computer
species of insects so that really
motivated me to think about this open
category work and and me and many other
people this is a hot topic in computer
but subscribe to people watching it this
video will open open category challenges
so the open category challenges that
I've taught my computer to tell the
difference among these 54 species but
then someone at test time shows me a
thing and says what is it and the
standard way that we train a machine
learning system it really only knows
that it thinks there are only 40 54
types of things in the universe so if
you stick your thumb into the camera and
it'll photograph it it would assign it
to one of those 54 categories now it
might say well I can't decide whether
it's this or that but it never enters
its mind so to speak that there might be
something else out there and so the
question is how could we have a computer
system that knows that it doesn't know
everything so it knows that it that it
knows these 54 things but there are
potentially thousands of other things
out there
and so it entertains that explicitly as
a possibility and so our strategy has
been to say for the computer so when we
train a computer system the standard way
is to ask it's kind of like when
training a physician what is what are
the key differences that would let you
tell if this is this is versus that I
mean if you've ever tried to recognize
bird species you know you're supposed to
look for like a red dot above the eye or
if you're learning to tell poisonous
mushrooms from from from delicious
mushrooms you maybe want to look for
gills or something and the same thing is
true for these insects but the the the
end result is that the computer has
learned to make these fine distinctions
but it doesn't really know what the
whole insect looks like it's just
looking for that red dot and not for
everything else so we instead want to
have the computer learn models of that
sort of just give it a sense of what
each of these species really looks like
so that when it sees my thumb it says
well that doesn't look like anything
that I saw in my training data so I
refused to assign it to one of my
four categories I'm gonna hand it's Eric
here who's an expert in he'll tell me
what it is yeah it's interesting to
think about all the things we can do to
give our systems either explicit or
implicit knowledge that the world is
bigger than they are much bigger and so
they're ready to deal with with being
humble about what they know and what
they don't know I think you've also
looked at this idea of how to do
reinforcement learning in a safe way or
you think think deeply about missing
exogenous variables for example right so
yeah the that came up more in not so
much that the exogenous variables are
missing but that they are present so if
you imagine I commit your knowledge is
missing of course because they're exact
so I mean this isn't really my own work
but I have looked at as you say I've
been surveying the literature and
there's some very nice work by Shimon or
and his students where they want one
intuition I think we all have is that in
situations where we know that we're
ignorant we should probably act more
conservatively and carefully and it
turns out we can make this precise
mathematically and show that if if we if
we minimize downside risk so the you
know when we're training reinforcement
learning systems we typically look at
like the expected reward or the expected
return and you might be looking at that
if you're investing in stocks on Wall
Street - you might say well I I want to
choose a mutual fund that has a high
expected return and that's what they
advertise in fact but maybe really
particularly as you get older you might
be concerned about downside risk and so
you might say well I want to invest in a
mutual fund that maybe it doesn't get
the highest overall risk but the
probability that I'll lose more than 50%
of my funds they like drive that near
zero and so we it turns out that we can
show that that kind of a notion that I
want to limit my downside risk is
equivalent to to dealing with average
maximize my average return when I'm
uncertain of the dynamics of the world
and so so this does confirm and in a
mathematical way that that it's good to
be conservative
when you when you don't know how the
world works
so so you've recently been weighing in
on this discussion which is evolving
just maybe the last year or two but it
goes back a long ways about innate
knowledge innate structure and
algorithms that intelligent systems
might have hearkening back to human
beings and going from toddlers into
adulthood
what's the innate innate abilities that
we have and what are we what do we learn
on top of that and and and their various
approaches to this that I and I think
you've been talking about but your own
perspective lately it's raising
questions about this in terms of of this
idea of the minimum a minimal system
that we might build someday and that
would do lifelong learning and become
brilliant in the world and be able to do
well what's on you current thoughts on
this this discussion well yeah so so
there's certainly a significant portion
of the AI research community and also I
think the general public when they think
about artificial intelligence they think
about something that would be like an
artificial human being or something that
would have the the same breadth of
knowledge as people do
whereas our current AI systems are
always extremely narrow it's hard to you
cannot overemphasize how narrow our
systems are I call these things sort of
brilliant savants I don't throw the word
idiot out too often but just narrow
solutions very very narrow and so and
and and that's a system we seem to know
how to to build right now and so I don't
know how does this connect to innate
miss I guess we observe in people that
that they do come into the world with
some degree of innate knowledge we we
can't interview them to find out what it
is but but they can do these studies on
infants of course well certainly
certainly toddlers seem to have way more
breadth well yeah systems can come close
to a three year
in terms of either their abilities in
like a few months old yeah that could be
so I mean it's not really my area of
expertise but certainly there are these
studies and also studies and other
animal species so we know that many
animals are well are born almost like
adults obviously a horse can already
stand and walk immediately after birth
whereas humans need need a adult human
to hang on for a year and before they
really are even start to be able to walk
so so one lesson you might take from
that is one of the things that's allowed
humans to be more broad is that we are
born with less built-in pre-wired
knowledge and and if we want AI systems
so so this is kind of the paradox is
that in order to get our narrow systems
even our narrow systems of work we build
in a ton of prior knowledge into them so
there's a huge amount of innate
knowledge although it's often not
explicit I mean you know innate
knowledge is not like that they've
memorized the times tables it's more
that there's some set of constraints so
that when those constraints combine with
the experiences that the system has then
it's able to rapidly do well in that
narrow area and one big thing we would
like to do is have our AI systems be
broader a lot of the mistakes that our
AI assistants making right now are
because they are so narrow that that
they might I mean we saw this case
recently of the you know I think it was
BMW that that that was that had this
self-driving car system right that they
had trained and then they took it to
Australia and it was being fooled by the
motions of kangaroos is had never really
seen kangaroos hopping around before and
and so that was an example of it was
just too narrow in one particular way
and they couldn't deal with this this
broader thing but also I think when we
look at a lot of these ethical
challenges of of of AI systems where
we're making Mis classification errors
that that are really offensive to some
people the computer is completely
oblivious to the fact that some people
might be insulted by by
being misclassified and or it could be
very insensitive for instance to be
positioning advertisements for funeral
homes opposite you know news stories
about car crashes or something why would
our customers be upset with that it's
because the computer system knows
nothing about life or death right yes
sir yes yeah so it's so we would
definitely like our computer systems to
be much broader and but to do that we
need to be building in less or or
building in different kind of innate
knowledge into them that because because
we know that if you try to learn
starting with nothing then it will
basically take you an infinite amount of
data to learn things and so there's a
very tight trade-off there between the
amount of experience we need and the
amount of knowledge we have to build
into the system you've been through many
different we'll call them dominant
paradigm Spector Kuhn of machine
learning
going from certainty factors and
heuristic methods through probabilistic
graphical models and now we're in this
era of of deep learning these general
generalized function learning with
differentiation and optimization what
she says with where things are going
especially in terms of the the rich
semantics and the semantic foundations
of learning systems yeah it's been quite
ride and I think also there's been a
pendulum swings back and forth between
whether we start with a formal
understanding and then the experiments
follow or we start with the experiments
and then the formal understanding
follows and we're definitely in a period
right now where there's this sort of
crazy experimentation many many people
have been very excited by the see people
have even called it alchemy well yes sir
I call it a giant hackathon that's like
the whole field aided and abetted by the
internet and archiving people just
posting papers and and software
frameworks and it's been an incredibly
productive time I think particularly
surprising because we have all these
large corporate interests in this and
many companies and yet we edit terrain
and
competitive terrain and yet there's a
tremendous sharing of the core tools and
and everybody's learning for everybody
else very quickly so so I mean I I think
right now deep learning is getting a lot
of attention but in parallel and and
what and why well because it's given us
an even more expressive set of functions
or class of models a language that lets
us be able to use machine learning to do
things we couldn't do before
and so that's and we and that really
required you know yes coming with the
language which we kind of had from
neural networks in the 90s but improved
algorithms much improved computation and
vastly improved data and all of those
things really coming together but those
same factors are at work on the
probabilistic modeling side so you know
you sort of left off with with latent
variable models but then we had Bayesian
nonparametric s-- and then we've now we
have probabilistic programming and
interestingly we now have probabilistic
programming systems that are compiling
to the same tensorflow
infrastructure that the deep learning
systems are compiling to and we're and
we're seeing lots of really interesting
interplay between probabilistic
reasoning for instance about say the
variational auto-encoders and and high
high dimensional density estimation I
think there's some extremely exciting
ideas happen in the synthesis of these
so this is really yes using neural
network type machinery but to do
probabilistic modeling because I think
ultimately we need to be able in order
to understand and debug and and and and
ensure the safety of these AI systems
make sure they're actually doing we want
them to we need to be able to understand
the what they've learned and the
intermediate semantics and I think the
only tool we have for that is it comes
out of probability which gives us a
declarative reading of what these
variables mean and it gives us you know
theory of identifiability of the
parameters and all of these things that
that we don't get from the pure function
learning approach
on the other hand the big lesson I think
that we have to take away from the
function learning was that in in
computer vision at least right we tried
we know that to go from pixels all the
way to saying oh that is a person
sucking on a lollipop or whatever that
is such a huge leap in interpretation
that that that we needed to have some
intermediate representations along the
way and we tried to hand engineer those
and we had sifter our fellow graduate
student David Lowe had invented this and
Paul viola and and and Hogg and so on
and it turned out these deep learning
things could just learn those
representations directly instead much
better than we could do them by hand so
so so we've learned that machine
learning often can beat a human hand
engineering but but particularly in that
sort of signal it's a symbol transition
area where where we just we we had no
shortage of data and we had and we but
we had this huge gap to cross so I think
we will see a lot more hybridization of
the techniques and I expect the higher
level systems will look a lot more like
probabilistic programming and and even
logical or relational type
representations but but but anything
dealing with signal data we now have
this really powerful tool and who knows
you know we can do an end-to-end
training of these systems now if we can
make all the components differentiable
and you know several people are using
this phrase differentiable programming
to serve describe what's going on that
these are not unformed neural networks
people really think very carefully about
they're really designing a skeletal
program which is then filled in with
data right a pipeline where you could
actually literally have a surface to
optimize over well and we have memory
units and we have time series units I
mean all kinds of again any things are
being programmed in and both in the
probabilistic frameworks and and in the
and in these deep learning frameworks we
have much more expressive languages and
ways of training and reasoning over them
and and you know there's huge advances
in in Hamiltonian Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo this is just so cool so so so Tom
you and I were were were involved in the
2008 2009
triple AI panel at long-term AI futures
and I think you actually you actually
co-chaired one of the subcommittee's I
think was on short-term disruptions and
back when we had the meeting at Asilomar
we had an gon get up and I asked him I
gave him a challenge and I said to kick
off this whole day at Asilomar with this
group thinking about long-term AI
futures tell us what's going to surprise
us and he gave up and gave it
essentially if you look back upon his
talk he gave a deep learning talk and
that was in February of 2009 and that
summer we had the the kind of fight the
first breakthrough I think at Microsoft
Research with with speech so if I ask
you that again now that we've been
through a few surprises with the power
of deep net to do object recognition and
so on and I asked you this question now
what might surprise us tom in the next
five to ten years what comes to mind
well one of the other things that we
talked about that I in in my group there
at Asilomar was AI enabled crime and and
we've just seen a very interesting
report come out across several
organizations about potential misuses of
the current AI technology you know and
it's clear there there are risks in
cybersecurity we now have the ability to
create extremely a high quality fake
video in which you and I could be saying
absolutely outrageous terrible things
and we which is sort of the automated
fake news problem so that those I'm
afraid we might have some very bad
surprises along those lines because
first of all we as people are kind of
suckers for the interesting story and
the conspiracy theory and we've seen
that at play in social media
but also our institutions are not
adapting as quickly as our algorithms
are at the same time I guess a reason
for hope there is that we are aware of
this and and many people are scrambling
to think about all these ethical and
social consequences of our of our
systems and the the industry even more
maybe than the universities is deeply
engaged in this and and of course your
leadership of the partnership for AI I
think is there going to be a key part of
preparing us for to move forward on that
how about technically those surprises I
mean what made you an upside in the
technical breakthrough well I would like
to say that we would have some beautiful
breakthroughs in say dialogue systems
that we could really have more than a
one step interaction with with Cortana
and and I think we'll see some progress
there but again it's going to have to be
narrow because you know it could be a
vision people like to say that anything
can appear in an image and natural
language people can say anything you can
talk about anything in speech in fact
unlike in images you can talk about
abstract things ideas and trends and
paradigms and and and our computer
systems don't have any idea what those
are and it would be and we don't know
how to program those ourselves and it's
hard to figure out how we're going to
get the training data for that either
we can't ground those the way we can
with with imagenet or or giant corpora
so so I guess I am not so optimistic
that but but but I do think that we can
have much better conversations than we
have now another area that I think is
going to be a huge opportunity is to
couple deep learning with all these
problems in medicine write everything in
metal medical imaging is in the middle
of being totally revolutionized because
these tools for deep learning that we've
been using for you know entertainment on
the web are now being transferred to to
understanding all of these complex
images in medicine so that's really
exciting I think
DDC implications for the
the nature of work and human jobs and
versus what machines do and so on what's
your you think what you're thinking
about well certainly there there are
some work including let's say the you
know my physician friends who described
their work as intellectual assembly line
work there are some aspects of many
knowledge worker type jobs that that
we'll be able to I won't say automate
necessarily but provide very good
assistance but I but I don't think that
we're going to see entire jobs go away
it's I think jobs are going to be
redefined so that some of the some of
the what was currently in a job
description will now be something we can
do very effectively with an AI tool and
and then other that everything will
rearrange as a result and and so I think
virtually every job category will
probably be affected by some of these
things just as the internet and the web
say transform travel agents or many
other things and yet you know I think
there are so many things where anything
that requires breath we know our
computer systems are going to continue
to be narrow for a long time and so I
think any job that requires breadth and
integration of information dealing with
humans and all the human things I I
think is is our areas that are going to
be critical you know Stuart Russell used
to make this point in in response to the
skeptics about AI who would say well
you're just making simulations he would
say well when a computer simulates
playing chess it's actually playing
chess and we have now a place go as well
but I think it's always going to be true
that when a computer simulates having
emotions it is just simulating having
emotions because not being human it
can't have any direct experience of
human emotion so it's always just going
to be struggling as an alien would
struggle to understand us and so I think
all of the all the job functions that
involve negotiation and understanding
people and human experience are going to
be very firmly in the in
place where humans will be doing this
yeah I'd like to think about this and I
resonate deeply is that with the rise of
automation around us that they'll be
even an amplification and a celebration
of human touch human caring may be using
the rise of a caring economy human human
experience so you mentioned earlier
about you like to get into applications
not just theory be in the open world
both technically as well as making
contributions there and you've done
incredible work in this this rising area
that you helped to define we call
computational sustainability now talk
more about how you got involved with the
whole the whole biological world and the
environment and applications there I
think it's such a exciting and important
space yes well I guess I would I like to
say it was a mid-career crisis because
you know after I got my PhD and I got
tenure and so on you know and I was
publishing lots of nice technical papers
but I didn't feel like I was having
enough impact in terms of problems that
really mattered and one of those is is
the environment and the threats from
climate change and so being at Oregon
State University it turns out there's
always a toss-up between Oregon State
and Yale and Cornell as to who's number
one in in ecology but at least I missed
a head on that that that that
competition but I believe it turns out
like yes so and so there there were
tremendous wonderful collaborators to
work with at Oregon State and so I got
involved gradually with several projects
and we started a training program a PhD
training program in what we were calling
at the time ecosystem informatics
although informatics maybe wasn't quite
the right word because it was more some
taneous lee trying to support ecologist
ecological scientists who are trying to
understand how ecosystems function but
also policymakers and like the EPA or
the four
servus or farmers and so on who are
actually managing an ecosystem trying to
make it work and and so building tools
helping giving them really taking the
modeling tools that we have from say
sequential decision making and and
decision analysis and and and making it
possible for them to apply them to these
challenging problems and so we also have
like a summer training program and then
we got these large grants from the
National Science Foundation and so then
and that one thing leads to another so I
on the supporting ecological science
side I got heavily involved
collaborating with the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology and and this brings us to
another one of your favorite topics
which is crowdsourcing so you know there
are many passionate bird watchers in the
world and Cornell was one of the first
organizations to try to engage them in
massive data collection efforts through
something they call a bird
where bird watchers can go out you know
go for a two-hour hike maybe and create
a checklist of all the birds they saw
along that hike and then they can upload
that to a website and and we promised we
were going to do science with that data
but then it turned out to be tricky to
do science with that data and so I was
one of many people working then on how
to take that data it was being collected
and figure out could we fit could we
understand bird habitat requirements
could we understand bird migration which
happens at continental scales with
billions of birds and so we've made some
progress on those on those questions and
it's been a load of fun and then on the
policy side I was looking at problems
say in wildfire management in the West
or an invasive species management and
there you have you know tight budgets
and you have to carefully choose what
actions to perform and you also have
some serious risks you know massive
fires or species extinctions or
agricultural challenges so lots of
interesting problems to work on so now
that you have a comma Emeritus after
your name you might be in a position to
give
advice to folks who are just starting
out in their careers about what to look
out for what to think about with reflect
about how to make decisions about a
career in computer science so I have
some thoughts you want to share with
with young computer scientists or people
you've been thinking about computer
science well I think it's important to
focus on the foundations right so and
that doesn't mean just taking like the
foundational classes in computer science
but more there's a temptation I think
and it's gotten very exaggerated lately
and machine learning that we jump
immediately to coding up an experiment
and running it and I think it's
important to first consider what are
what are the sort of scientific
hypotheses that you're testing too much
of experimental computer science has
turned into demos rather than into
really asking what are the questions
that that we really need to answer in
order to move our understanding of
computing forward and then what
experiments can I do to answer those
questions really taking a scientific
approach to things rather than just
trying to grab for the low-hanging fruit
of whatever current paradigm is popular
and it's tough because the reviewers at
conferences may be looking for you know
what's hot right now and maybe they
haven't thought about some of those
other things for a while but I but I
think you need a rudder that's heading
you toward you know success in the long
term and and and I think and also a part
of that I think is keeping yourself
honest by working on real problems and
so nowadays the secret is collaboration
right you really need particular if you
want to dive deep into a domain you you
can't simultaneously be an expert in the
domain and an expert in computer science
although you tried with an MD at a PhD
but but you really need to find a
collaborator who can also do that deep
dive with you and they need to be
willing to also learn some computer
science so that and you have to budget a
year or two just to to learn the
of each other's fields and understand
also the I say social standards and
mores what what counts as a research
result and how can you both succeed but
the payoff then is that you can not only
discover new and important computer
science questions but you can have an
impact in in those fields as well you've
been a fabulous adviser to so many
students your webpage that's a big list
of all the successful students that have
done PhDs with you any advice for
getting through a dissertation and the
whole process this is more practical
right yes well I think first of all it's
certainly it's normal to feel despair at
various points in the PhD and to feel
that I remember when I was stuck in my
third year which seemed to take two or
three years of trying to decide well
what would my thesis be about I came at
you endlessly yes yes you did I think I
went through seven different topics or
something everything either seemed
impossible or too easy and the lesson I
learned was the two easy problems we're
all so hard so so so I think it's you
know it's good to do I mean Donald Knuth
has this advice right he says you know
first solve a problem that will take you
a minute and then maybe one that will
take you an hour and then the one
they'll take you a day and then one that
you think will take you a month and then
one that ends up taking you a year and
then you graduate so so I think the iíve
taught research methods and I and and
you know there's all these methods about
well how to do a statistical test
correctly but I think the number one
question of research methodology is what
do I do this today when I come into my
office and sit down that is going to
move me forward on this project and as
long as you do something every day that
does that you'll move forward and you
probably won't feel so so despair well
yes but you just have to pace yourself
and realize that yes progress happens in
small increments and and you should have
a back-up plan because everything many
things will fail along the way so you
need a fallback strategy you shouldn't
put all your eggs in one basket
well thanks Thomas been great talking to
you just been a great pleasure thank you